[Music]  very nice story here in california we  talk a lot about about the downer  stories this is a sweet story i wanted  to mention a 105 year old woman edith  kirkmaier  has been in the news because she's 105  she recently got her driver's license  yeah amazing she went down to the dmv  she passed her test and i was thinking  about this today you've just got to  admire that spirit at 105 to keep going  to live life to the fullest and i wanted  to congratulate her personally so i  invited her here on the show let's bring  her out here okay edith let's do it yeah  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  sorry about the deaf people  [Applause]  here kirk my everybody it's okay edith  thank you thank you  that's edith favorite part  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  that car is as one of those  transmissions you control with your mind  yeah  i just love that those idiots were  killed by a car going one mile an hour